um we have been hearing a lot about this
game called Five Nights at Freddy's so
we grabbed it and right off of steam and
we're just going to go ahead and check
it out I've never played it before I've
never never seen I've never seen
anything about it except for this creepy
intro screen I haven't even seen
screenshots of it so I have no idea what
I'm in for
um and I'm pretty
excited so um yeah let's just get into
it and see how it is let's see let's see
how scary Five Nights at Freddy really
is Freddy's pizzeria is looking for
security
guard oh that's it's probably
me the security guard
great
okay hello
hello uh I wanted to record a message
for you to help you get settled in on
your first night
um I actually worked in that office
before you I'm finishing up my last week
now as a matter of fact so I know it can
be a bit overwhelming but I'm here to
tell you there's nothing to worry about
you'll do fine so let's just focus on
getting you through your first week okay
okay uh let's see first there's an
introductory greeting from the company
that I'm supposed to read it's kind of a
legal thing you know um welcome to to
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza a magical place
for kids and grown-ups alike where
fantasy and fun come to life fazry
entertainment is not responsible for
damage to property or person upon
discovering that damage or death has
occurred a missing person report will be
filed within 90 days or as soon as
property and premes cleaned and bleached
and the carpets have been replaced blah
blah blah now that might
sound there really nothing to worry
about the animatronic characters here do
get a bit quirky at night but do I blame
them no if I were forced to sing those
same stupid songs for 20 years and I
never got a bath I'd probably be a bit
irritable at night too so remember these
characters hold a special place in the
hearts of children and we need to show
them a little respect right okay so just
be aware the characters do tend to
wander a bit uh they're left in some
kind of free roaming mode at night
something about their servos locking up
they get turned off for too long that's
Terri to walk around during the day too
but then there was The Bite of 87 sounds
like this entire game is being played
through cameras I don't think I even
move you know now concerning your safety
the only real risk to you as a night
Watchman there if any is the fact that
these
characters if they happen to see you
after hours probably won't recognize you
as a
person they they'll most likely see you
as a metal endoskeleton without its
costume on now since that's against the
rules here at Freddy Fazbear's Pizza
they'll probably try to forcefully stuff
you inside of a Freddy Fazbear suit um
now that wouldn't be so bad if the suits
themselves weren't filled with cross
beams wires and animatronic devices
especially around the facial area so you
can imagine how having your head for be
pressed inside one of those could cause
a bit of discomfort and
death the only parts of you that would
likely see the light of day again would
be your eyeballs and teeth and they pop
out the front of the
Mask yeah they don't tell you these
things when you sign up but hey first
they should be a breeze I'll chat with
you tomorrow uh check those cameras and
remember to close the doors only if
absolutely necessary got to conserve
power okay all right good night okay so
it sounds s like I'm not supposed to use
this cameras unless I'm really supposed
to I think I
will am I only supposed to use these
doors when I need
to
great
so I only have 58% of power
already am I just supposed to stay in
here and not use my cameras like
obviously I want to use
them wait wasn't there something here
before oh for God's sakes do you guys
ever see um A Goofy Movie um and like
those creepy
animatronic
song um part of the movie and
um it was like raining and there was
like mud and stuff and like one of the
animatronics got like smashed up or
something and he had like mud and his
eyeballs were popping out and it was
like you know a
comedy but also
scary
um
what's
happening I just want to know what's
happening kitchen
cam is so
disabled
oh oh my
God I close
game I didn't hit
exit did I
lose
scared I didn't close the
game I want it to be clear that I did
not close the game I didn't hit Escape
so I don't know how that
happened
probably should have hit continue
instead I wonder if apparently you got
the Easter egg on
your um someone told me I might have
gotten the Easter egg on my first play
through so hooray lucky
me I don't see why closing a door
continues to use
battery hello hello
hello uh I wanted to record a message
for you to help you get settled in on
your first night so this one was the one
that moved
there's there's three
here I know it can be a bit overwhelm
one two three I'm tell you there's to
worry about there's nothing over here
let's just focus on getting you through
your first week okay uh let's see
there's a few masks here one two three
four and like kind of like The Body
Machine here oh and there's this guy in
the corner one two three four
five um this doesn't really have
anything going
onment is
not occuring this
is some kind of Creo hallway
blah blah
blah rules for safety don't run don't
yell don't scream don't poop on the
floor
don't stay close to Mom don't touch
Freddy that's good advice don't hit
leave before dark what kind of family
fun place is this camera 6 has always
been disabled and Camera 7 is like the
entryway of the bathrooms um note that
there are
no no cameras in the bathrooms because
it's not that kind of
game
um too but then there was The Bite of
87 yeah it's amazing that the human body
can live without the fral lo I feel like
conning your safety the only real risk
to you the night watch here if is the
fact that these
characters I feel like this is mostly
about figuring out which direction these
animatronic characters are coming from
do they come
from if they come from here camera
a they could go easily
into here near camera 1 B where I would
see
them um or they could go this way wer
with CR um which would be way harder
because I don't have as much time to
find
themt only I think we idea is to find
out what direction they're coming
from so that I can close that door in
time first station the breze I'll chat
with you tomorrow check those remember
to close the doors only if absolutely
necessary got to conserve power all
right good
night
okay
so he's still there that's good a good
good
start um I'm already at
61% that's not so hot I feel like the
batteries go pretty fast around
here
um you got the banjo player there's a
tambourine guy
guitarist a little bit of anxiety no big
deal it's my first night on the job I
want to do a good
job he's still there that's
good that dude is still
there it's
great
oh H
oh okay all right all cameras are
done he's gone
again
um like oh what's
that this
thing I just want to see
him who's
there this is the worst Chuck-E-Cheese
I've ever been
to do you see
anything
I'm going to keep checking the doors
because I have no idea where he's oh
no I
think he's in the
hall fudge he's coming coming from the
Left
Right show
yourself you creepy
animatronic
bear oh
God
screw you I used both of
them oh my
God I can hear
it I can 100% hear
it is he
here am I
dead I don't see anything I'm scared to
use my
cameras because I think he's
here and I'm running out of
battery oh my God where is it when is
the my shift over is it over at 6:00
a.m. cuz I'm pretty close and I'm hungry
and I think if you work 6 hours you get
a break I think that's the
law oh there's always a blind spot like
no matter what I
do
okay I almost made it you guys through
my first
night come on come on 6:00
a.m. I'm just a working
man oh
God I feel
like I have a lot of battery
left well I don't but I mean it's almost
6: a.m. it has to be really close come
on
who you think made all those posters
like there's some cute little kid
drawings what kids giving us drawings
during the
day they had such a fun
time ah I did it I did
it I made it 6:
a.m. I survived was good made my first
night so I think I get I think I get the
overall concept of the game is to figure
out the
direction that they're
walking and um use that to kind of
watch hello hello hello well if you're
he l you made it the day to
congrats I won't talk quite as long this
time since Freddy and his friends tend
to become more active as the week
progresses uh it might be a good idea to
peek at those cameras while I talk just
to make sure everyone's in their proper
place you know interestingly fredd
himself doesn't come off
[__] I've already lost one I guess
that's one more reason not to run out of
power right
I also want to emphasize the importance
of using your door
lights God to be right outside your
doors so if you can't
find or someone on youram sure to check
the door light you might only have a few
seconds to react
je danger of course I'm not implying
that also check on the C Pirate Cove
from time to time the character in there
seems unique he becomes more active the
Camas remain off for long periods of
time I guess he doesn't like being
watched I don't know anyway I'm sure you
have everything under control talk to
you
soon so the Pirate Cove monster doesn't
like being
watched oh
God
it's freaking
huge do you guys hear
anything feel
like feel like
I'm okay no big
deal
it's only 1:
a.m. need to conserve power a little
bit just hang
out you guys hearing stuff I'm hearing
stuff you hear
it
okay I have no idea where they're coming
from I can't see anything on my cameras
and I can't use it because it's only 2:
a.m. and I only have 64% of my battery
so I'm probably going to
die
where is that
bear okay okay he's on camera three
which means he's coming from the left
again
what the
light
is it
working neither is the
door the
bear the bear got
me well the bear got
me
crap
okay I I saw that he was coming but I
couldn't turn off the light or I
couldn't turn on the light and I
couldn't shut the
door so I'm not really sure how to
protect against
that freaking
bear
whatever I'm never seen a bunny that's
small or big that was
terrifying all right I don't
understand is this one do I have to keep
watching
him I kind of want
to is he going to
ring
like okay they work
now check the
Cove hear
it
h h
H
okay still
there all right I need to consider
battery
oh
God I can hear
it but I don't see
anything
it is that
like damn it I'm the worst security
guard I can't stop these damn animals
from killing me
okay maybe I'm spending too long on the
cameras
and I need to be more
observant um in my
space in this area where I can
clearly protect
myself
so I'll just let's do this
again I'm going to make it to at least
day
on my brand new
job oh
okay okay here we
go
okay
hello
oh
okay so he's already there which means I
think he's pretty close to being
there how long am I allowed to do
this go away you
bastard all right well I found him
that's
good
that's totally something that's Bear
Town I'm in Bear
Country come on you bastard show your
stupid
face it was on the
left anyone who's just joining me um I'm
playing Five Nights of Freddy I have to
survive five nights being a security
guard at Freddy's fun house I'll check
my other
one I only have this much battery ah I
scared myself
I only have five I only have a limit I
only have a limited amount of
battery and I have to stop these jerks
from trying to shove me in a suit and
murdering me so the animatronics come
alive at
night
dear
Lord
hello oh bear bear Town bear
town so I had to pick the direction
they're probably going to come at me
listen for them turn on the light and
shut the door before they kill
me and they can totally
come from both
doors I can hear
it can hear
it my God I still have three hours
left so it's 3:00 a.m. I'm the night
shift so I have to make
it to 6:00
a.m. and also
celebrate
Fox you're a goddamn
baby
hi I just want to
live I have so much more to
do I didn't even make it to day
three this is the worst job I've ever
had I mean this night watch job gam
spots are
fud all
right
Fox let's do it
again I'm going
to oh he's already
gone
is that something in the
hallway it's honestly so hard to
tell
like oh
okay where are
you
screw
it it's only
midnight do you hear
anything
I
don't see anything so I think I'm
okay die you
bastard
okay
God what is like a things trying to kill
me I got a bear in the Supply Closet a
terrifying bunny in the dining area oh
fudge
I
hate this
game show
yourself I hate
you
Bears it was in the Supply
Closet
I know it's up
there
okay
okay I got
it
why how long is it going to stay out
there
jeez For the Love of
butts
God
just creeping on my
door what's that what's that what's that
what's
that oh that's so animatronic I think
that's the fox that's the fox nobody
scare me get away from me Eric you're
not sneaky at all my co-workers
suck they're sitting around with masks
stomping around like
they're
for God's sakes how long is he out
there it's 3:00
a.m. oh a damn
it
dang dang
it and fox is so fast Eric you're not
sneaky I got co-workers sneaking around
me in masks trying to freak me
out
ah I can't I really want to get to night
three but I don't want to play
anymore look at the Cove the fox runs if
the Cove is not watched so I think I
have to keep my eye on the
Cove I think that's my problem is that I
have to I have to keep watching the
Pirates Cove even if I don't want
to which I
don't all
right good old Pirate
Cove all
right
everything's hunky
dory oh
cameras
good good and my job is
done
watching you Pirate
Cove all right so I'm hearing both to
watch Fox's Cove and to not watch Fox's
Cove can you all right he's gone
oh he's in the dining
area
off Eric you're not
sneaky you're the
wor you have to be more
sneaky my coworkers are lurking around
I'm trying to play this
game get
away oh my
God he's in the freaking bathroom
closet I cannot play this with you like
this go away
there's foxes everywhere I
can't run out
battery and
heart
I'm trying to watch The Cove but I
didn't see anything in the
Cove I heard it did you hear
it I heard
it Pirate Cove nothing going
on for God's sakes
buunny
[__] just lurking
around
ridiculous go
away
damn
it that dude has been hanging out for so
long I'm sick of
it what
Shadows
oh
bear sounds like when I turn on the
light oh my God
bunny
okay I think he's
gone when I turn on the light there's a
shadow on the wall and if there's a
bunny there I'll see
him
oh
I can hear
it he's in the Supply
Closet he's in the west
hle running out of freaking
battery
oh my God I'm freaking
out he's in the
kitchen the kitchen is to the
right
great
great why isn't my left door
working I'm going to freaking
die
he's in the
kitchen
um go away duck I don't want to eat I'm
all hungry go
away
Fox the
fox that's stupid
Fox that's stupid Fox
all right this is taking more strategy
than I had initially
thought seems
like I had to keep an eye on the Cove to
keep the
fox from killing
me the duck
and the duck and the
bunny are like walking up to get
me the bear comes whenever he
wants like I don't see how I can
possibly
survive
oh when these animatronics take pity on
me like I'm
exhausted I need a
nap I was never meant to be a security
guard God he's
gone he's
gone
no
like I'm freaking
out damn
it
oh what is that just one
left
God bless
it
like the
bunny or the bear should be coming
really
soon where are you you
bastards guys I'm shut in the
God what's that
noise did you hear
it heard
it was it the fox I hate that goddamn
Fox West
Hall okay two of them are
out nothing in Pirate Cove so I
don't I think it's in West
Hall there's nothing
in there's nothing in the Cove so am I
just supposed to keep watching it even
though there's nothing in
there where is
that you hear
it you hear
it
oh my God I hear
it all right watching The
Cove go open Out The
Cove there's nothing in the
cove
jeez just freaking making me sit here
turn this light on and
off the duck comes from the right but I
didn't hear anything from the kitchen
you should hear like like kitchen pots
like clangs and stuff like that before I
I think the duck will come and kill me
so I think I think I'm
good this is based on
nothing um but previous
deaths
so I'm just
assuming oh God I'm checking the
code
like okay bear in the Supply Closet
he'll be coming pretty
soon come on bear you
bastard show your bear
face out there I'm the best
damn security
guard this chuckecheese has ever
seen
live oh God bear where are
you hear it you hear
it
what does that
mean can I do
this Bunny's still
there what do that
mean I don't have enough battery to keep
this
up the bunny won't F
off
okay should I check the Pirate
Cove I am like super watching you fox
totally checking out the
fox just like we
discussed
should I check on him
again
Fox oh
oh bear to the
right bear to the
right
come on bear where are
you I saw him I remember he was on the
right the bear was to the
right
[__] I'm losing it
great I'm I'm like running out of
battery here I got 9% of battery
left
8% come
on you hear
it
[__] I'm at three 4%
battery great 3%
battery 5:
a.m. this is it people this is what our
training was for when we trained to be
security guards at a
Chuck-E-Cheese with insane animat ronic
homicidal animals people this is ah you
[__]
well
damn
it I was so
close if you run I think maybe if you
run out of batteries the fox just comes
and gets you I was so
close I think I need to learn how to
conserve more um that's pretty much an
hour stream for us I definitely want to
play this again I think um I'll probably
try
to all my own time like we'll just go
through it try to get nights three four
and five and like scope them out at a
later time um but for now I think we got
to wrap it
up what did I think of Five Nights at
Freddy well my first two nights sucked
uh it's
terrifying um there's not a lot to it I
just think um but it it does take
strategy like there's definitely
strategy and planning involved that I
haven't gotten yet um so it's a fun game
I'll def Ely I'm definitely going to
pick it up again and and try to try to
get further at least tonight three I'm
the worst security guard ever anyway
thanks for joining me we'll definitely
um try to stream this again or at least
put up um a summary video on Gamespot so
stay tune to gamespot.com for more
terrifying games that I'll probably play
and scream at all right thanks guys
bye